hi YouTube my name is Adam Mutambara one
of the opposition leaders from Zimbabwe
i'm linda was attending the World
Economic Forum as part of the young
global leaders one thing that companies
countries and individuals have to do
differently is the way they understand
the nature of global challenges and the
way they develop and construct solutions
to those challenges we live in a very
interdependent world where global
challenges are interconnected climate
change globalization poverty human
rights hiv/aids the interconnected and
hence we need their own listed and
inclusive understanding of those global
challenges such that you can't save the
globe around climate change for America
without addressing poverty hiv/aids and
governance issues in Africa is you
address climate change is you create
address terrorism you must address the
grievances of the poor you know sir
dress colleges of hiv/aids a holistic
and inclusive approach to creating
solutions to global challenges for
example more specifically the world must
take a vested interest approach to the
crisis in Zimbabwe because an injustice
anyway is an injustice every way there
will be only one kind of victory global
victory for the human race in one planet
we are in this fight and destroy
together